[Applaus]
beim winter infrage
guten tag sie sind meine heutigen
teilnehmer nämlich an
storkow willst du die uci vor den
binding stößt ich bin nicht die gucci
ich bin charlotte von dem stoff
wir haben vom king cigna und gesängen
und
möchten sie sich nicht vorstellen ich
bin
wie bitte
warum ihr grüner der super illu
aufpreis
inklusive bin im
coaching du willst hier gelernt wie man
sie ja führt hätte befinden immer auch
super bekommen sie ganzen scheiße spuren
aus kreisen hier in kultur bekannter
grundsatz aufrissen er ist das coaching
dann das essen
gut was wissen sie über etikette doch
dieser mesic kratzen in der rechtzeitig
also schneidet das wissen sie alle da
trägt eigentlich nicht darauf rein die
uci vollkommen recht
spinnst du spürst du gesagt vergessen
wir das anders lassen sie uns eine
typische restaurant situation simulieren
auf geht's zum sporteln eigentlich
wollen nicht dass die jacke wieder damit
vorbei konnte die shimano dura damit er
weiß der hund aus fahrzeug bevor sie ja
dann ist
er der jugend
oder dies mit ananassaft oder vielleicht
hommes oder
wie es mit dem stuhl erfreuten die sowie
jugendmarketing prinzipiell sehr gut
aber sie müssen die damen natürlich vor
bahnen wie bitte
[Musik]
und den kaugummi machen wir bitte raus
sprichst du du richtig ist mainburg und
dicht wie die netze gibt es dann bei
etwas zum essen der wert grantig ja
gleich
ich habe er mir süden nicola trotz
geringer erlebt so groß ist wie
contact antun perick nur notorische gold
in der us cart büßt zur ruhe kommt
super
erst die damen hunger
ja wenn er wie die
kampflos für
mein bist du bleibt das ist ein hammer
dieses ganz warstein ist
dessen wohnung durch war und
nur ein drittel ein kleiner pieks er zum
kuscheln zum arsch
der welt erklärt deutschland werde die
spur der tür in cottbus und wie man doch
zum uni wird gingen klinar dies morgen
geschieht
rating kunst überfressen die erste
ministerin noch sofort
endlich geschafft
gießen haben möchte ich dir einfach
nicht mehr um die wurst
[ __ ] wissens